la fille d'elon musk fait son coming-out
trans et elle veut couper les ponts avec
son père on vous raconte viviane jean
wilson a déposé une demande pour changer
de nom et de prénom pour que ces
derniers correspondent à son identité de
genre mais aussi pour ne plus être
associé à son père pour expliquer l
écrit je n'habite plus avec mon père
biologique et je ne veux plus être
associé à lui sous quelque forme que ce
soit elon musk qui n'a pas encore
répondu à ce sujet avait été critiqué en
2020 après des tweets sur le fait que
les personnes transgenres non binaire
demande à être identifiées par certains
projets soutient absolument les transmet
tous et prononçons des cauchemars
esthétique il souhaitait ensuite pour se
défendre que tesla avait obtenu une note
de 100 % dans l' indice d'égalité qui
détermine les meilleurs endroits où
travailler pour les personnes lgbt
l'audience de sa fille viviane pour le
changement de nom est prévue ce vendredi